it will be interesting to get your
thoughts about
mimetic theory where we're imitating
each other
in the context of this idea of
uniqueness
how much truth is there to that uh how
compelling is this
world view to you of gerardian
mimetic theory of desire where
maybe you can explain it from your
perspective but it seems like imitating
each other is the fundamental
property of the behavior of uh human
civilization
well imitation is not unique to humans
right monkeys imitate
um so a certain amount of learning
through observing
is not unique to humans humans do more
of it
uh it's actually kind of worth speaking
to this for a moment
monkeys can learn new behaviors new
we've even seen
teaching an ape sign language and then
the ape teaching other apes
sign language um so that's a kind of
mimesis right
kind of learning through imitation
and that needs to happen if they need to
learn or develop capacities that are not
just coded by their genetics right
so within the same genome they're
learning new things based on the
environment
and so based on someone else learn
something first and
so let's pick it up uh how
much a creature is the result of just
its genetic programming and how much
it's learning is a very interesting
question and i think this is a place
where humans
really show up radically different than
everything else and you
can see it in the in the neony how long
we're basically
fetal um that a
the closest ancestors to us if we look
at a chimp a chimp can
hold on to its mother's fur while she
moves around day one
and obviously we see horses up and
walking within 20 minutes
the fact that it takes a human a year to
be walking and it takes
20 minutes and you say how many
multiples of 20 minutes go into a year
like that's a long period of
helplessness that it wouldn't work for a
horse right like they
or anything else and and
not only could we not hold on to mom in
the first day
it's three months before we can move our
head volitionally um
so it's like why why are we embryonic
for so
long basically that it's like
like it's still fetal on the outside had
to be because
couldn't keep growing inside and
actually ever get out with big heads and
narrower hips from going upright
so here's a place where there's a
co-evolution of the pattern of humans
specifically here are our neony and what
that portends to learning
with our being tool-making and
environment modifying creatures
which is because we have the abstraction
to make tools
we change our environments more than
other creatures change their
environments
the next most environment modifying
creature to us is like a beaver
and then you we're in la you fly into
lax and you look at the just
orthogonal grid going on forever in all
directions
and you know we we've recently come into
the anthropocene where the surface of
the earth is changing more from
human activity than geological activity
and then beavers and you're like okay
wow we're really in a class of our own
in terms of environments
modifying yeah so as
soon as we started tool making
we were able to change our environments
much more radically we could put on
clothes and go to a cold place right
and this is really important because we
actually went and became apex predators
in every environment
we functioned like apex predators but
polar bear can't leave the arctic
right and the lion can't leave the
savannah and
orca can't leave the ocean and we went
and became apex predators in all those
environments because of our tool
creation capacity we could become better
predators than them adapted to the
environment or at least with our tools
adapted to the environment
so in every aspect towards any organism
in any environment we're incredibly good
at becoming apex predators
yes and nothing else can do that kind of
thing
there there is no other apex predator
that
you see the other apex predator is only
getting better at being a predator
through evolutionary process that's
super slow and that super slow process
creates co-selective process with their
environment so as the predator becomes a
tiny bit faster
it eats more of the slow prey the genes
of the fast prey and breed and the prey
becomes faster
and so there's this kind of balancing
and we in
because of our tool making we increased
our predatory capacity faster than
anything else could increase its
resilience to it
as a result we start outstripping the
environment and extincting species
following stone tools and going and
becoming apex predator everywhere this
is why we can't keep applying apex
predator series because we're not an
apex predator we're an apex predator but
we're something much more than that
um like just for an example the top apex
predator in the world in orca
an orca can eat one big fish at a time
like one tuna
and it'll miss most of the time or one
seal
and we can put a mile-long drift net out
on a single boat
and pull up an entire school of them
right we can
deplete the entire oceans of them that's
not an orca right like that's not an
apex predator
and that's not even including that we
can then genetically engineer different
creatures
we can extinct species we can devastate
whole ecosystems we can make built
worlds that have no natural things that
are just human-built worlds we can build
new types of natural creatures synthetic
life
so we are much more like little gods
than we are like apex predators now but
we're still behaving as apex predators
and little gods that behave as apex
predators causes a problem kind of core
to my assessment
of the world so what does it mean to be
a predator so a predator
is somebody that effectively can
mine the resources from a place so for
their survival
or is it also just purely
like higher level objectives of violence
and what is
can predators be predators towards the
same
each other towards the same species like
we think are we using the word predator
sort of generally which then connects to
conflict
and uh military conflict violent
conflict
in the space of uh human species
obviously we can say that plants are
mining the resources of their
environment in a particular way
using photosynthesis to be able to pull
minerals out of the soil
and nitrogen and carbon out of the air
and like that
and we can say herbivores are being able
to mine and concentrate that so i
wouldn't say
mining the environment is unique to
predator predator is
you know
generally being defined as mining
other animals right we don't consider
herbivores
predators but um an animal
which requires some type of violence
capacity because animals move
plants don't move so requires some
capacity to
overtake something that can move and try
to get away
you